[Musique]
pour moi la musique c'est assez
ambitieux la partie du dialogue
je cherche que la musique était donné
des émotions et surtout à travers de la
psychologie du personnage
[Musique]
sergio leone l'aise dans ses films une
part prépondérante
la musique de ennio morricone on filme
adu est paramétré dit il ya deux façons
de recevoir un filet la vue et l'ouïe la
vue représentent 50%
oui l'autre 50 pouces
[Musique]
mes méthodes de travail avec sergio
tiennent compte de cette théorie qui
porte ses conséquences sur le plan
pratique tous les metteurs en scène ne
tiennent pas compte de cette théorie
sans doute peu importante pour eux il
est clair qu'avec les autres je ne
travaille pas comme avec sergio moi je
travaille en tenant compte de cette
exigence queen dès maintenant pour la
méthode je commence à travailler
cergy on me raconte l'histoire 1 montre
m'indiquer cadrage qui fait toute la
mise en scène pour moi les connaissant
son style je sais bien comment sera
filmé la séquence
je commence à écrire la musique lui me
dit non je continue à écrire et lui
continue à dire non et comme ça on
avance un bon moment et c'est ce qu'ils
disent enfin oui
[Musique]